in this video we have the world's best
minecraft player Carl yes it's me like
we actually have dream this is his
YouTube channel he hold this video world
records he's insane he's good too
and over here I have 100 random innocent
minecraft players that dream is about to
slay they're so innocent they have no
idea that they're about to go up against
literally the best minecraft player to
ever walk the face of minecraft better
than techno blade claimed by him i
finished third techno finish night
where's techno at where's techno at how
many times I gonna say I've never said
that in one video what I'm gonna do is
I'm gonna TP players in until they
eventually kill dream have attic server
TP to people in let's see if two people
can at least touch dream oh you better
watch out dream ones got a wooden shovel
what are you gonna do this time I'm
gonna give this guy a diamond sword
dream are you just gonna sit up here and
snipe them should i oh my gosh viewers
are probably currently punching the air
they're like come on they don't stand a
chance they don't have armor and the
reason is because we have a hundred
people now do you think it's gonna be
this easy one a hundred people are
punching dream probably for him yes
where did the other guy go he's IV oh
he's hiding right back here he's shaking
his head at me no no Chris you're
cheatin hey we just gotta speed things
up man this kid's got not staying in a
chance you get better get better oh so
that was wrong too let's spice it up a
server can you spawn five random people
at the gate for the lion I'm gonna give
them some stuff alright I don't want
dream to just slaughter them helplessly
there we go alright oh they're fighting
each other your guys are fighting trees
how are you gonna kill the best player
in the world if you're just hitting each
other someone should explain to them
that if they kill dream they get $10,000
oh we got a guy he's making a move
Oh dreams getting sweaty on the stairs
they're running away alright let's see
oh he didn't even get him once
oh he just jumped on this kid's head oh
my gosh oh he got one hit oh that's good
hello contestant we are gonna be
spawning random ones of you in an arena
with dream and if you kill dream you get
$10,000 we're going until one of you
kill
dream good luck
alright server can you spawn ten people
in and now dream they know that you're
the target now they're actually a
coherent unit oh here they come boys
all right here's the Horde I'm gonna
drop them stuff whoever killed stream
gets $10,000 yes and I put them ahead of
the acre
whoops who did that oh oh you just
sniping people I'm the best micro better
in the world hey I gave this kid this
sword let's see if it works
oh I guess it didn't this minecraft
Steve doesn't stand a chance
oh he's dodging okay okay
while dream is currently focused on this
fight server can you spot another ten
people oh let's let's load them up hit
and hit them all with some leather armor
guys bomb brush up are you killing me oh
that's not you I thought that was you
there's so many people dressed up like
Jimmy no you what did you just do
we gave him a special trident and let
them fly around like Emperor Palpatine
and Star Wars I am better than take no
blade dream how many hearts do you oh oh
this guy's putting some bleep blah Blee
Bloo Blee Bloo Blee blob boy oh darn it
I keep you hidden
please Bloo that's not even hitting
dream oh yeah did you dream are you how
are you doing how many hearts you had
I'm doing perfectly fun oops
that Oh what's a done table to give away
I'm sorry yeah I think that was all on
you actually throughout this whole video
to make it even harder me Karl Chris and
Chandler are gonna pick you with arrows
the entire time
haha no you have to dodge our arrows
while also killing random people take
some swiftness boys get Swift Oh blue
blue back those were people that came
out of nowhere
here a server spawn 20 people everyone
go after dream ah there's a lot of
people there is and I'm pegging him mean
Jim you're just like I said just walking
on air Chandler yes your job is to equip
everyone that is not dream give them
unlimited leather and sword leather
might be oh oh that wasn't even me I'm
gonna join their discord give him some
motivation I'm gonna give the guy with
diamond armor strength potion why aren't
you guys killing dream if you kill him
you get ten thousand smackaroonies ten
Mick flurries tell raisin youtube to
stop killing other people this kids only
going after other people
raisin stop being a Spaghettio raisin
are you in here yes hi stop killing
people your job is to kill dream and no
one else someone killed me so I'm
getting my you know well stop okay
alright I feel like the numbers have
been weaned server can you spawn 20 more
people oh god yeah this is too easy
dream you know what you're right this is
too easy
hey server spawn another 10 on top of
those 20 people yo that's a lot of
numbers yo I gotta give these people
food and armor there's 40 people in this
arena now dream what will you do I will
kill them alright it seems simple enough
the dreams up to 43 kills it's been so
easy so far oh all right give him
diamond swords no no I didn't I
I did not diamond swords I did not say
that already doing it I'm already on it
baby
Oh dream is it easy getting knocked off
oh never no leave me alone
if they were smart they would all just
rush dream well they just tried and then
they ran yeah here I'm gonna go try to
encourage them yo diamond boy come on
contestants why don't you guys all bum
rush them at the same time yeah
long brush dream I told them all the
bumpers you oh wait they listen
all right dream how will you get out of
this one ah good they're all there
I'm giving poison arrows oh he missed it
I'm fine I'm fine
oh there he goes with the tried it all
right Jim oh oh he got stuck oh he's
going off with the boat a dream oh oh
okay he killed one all right here's what
we're gonna do
Carl Chandler you guys go into survival
mode join them in fighting dream oh I
kind of want to fight dream all right
how about all three of you go joy I
sounds good oh we did oh wait you guys
got diamond armor too
yeah I don't know who gave it to me
maybe it was me when I was in creative
mode no he wants this raising guy dead
so badly I want him dead get back here
raisin more like runs in ha ha
guys get out of my way I'm there are so
many people just constantly I want to go
up the stairs here oh we broke his
helmet we've broken salad my armor is
gonna start deteriorating yeah come on
dream I'm gonna beat you and then I'm
uploading it on YouTube oh I'm dead
dream once you kill everyone on the
arena will replenish your armor that's
assuming I'm dying yes all these people
Jamie's taking a while to kill him I'm
starting to question whether or not
you're the best player in the world
they're all they're all bombarding me
how's reason not dead yet
oh he's gonna shoot the arrows through
the doorway like he does oh your boots
broke his boots are gone no that's two
diamonds here Oh God prepare to die
dream no don't hit me what do you stop
oh you gotta my armor is almost done
we've come to join the fight where is he
please Diaries and snipe and snipe him
from afar I'm going in close a v3
oh my armors totally broken Chile's full
Pride and chanted everything Chandler
you can't have that much stuff get rid
of all your pride there we go
lies I'm all I'm all fresh wait Chris
did you give him his armor vex oh I gave
him his armor back because I believed in
him he wasn't supposed to get armor
until he killed everyone Chris that
wasn't supposed to happen dream I need
you to drop your helmet stop what you're
doing and drop your helmet dream I want
to kill this dumb raisin guy I'm gonna
get raised in a potion of slowness he's
dead now he's dead now there's no way
well summer this guy comes and saves
them all right there we go
he's dead now there's no there's no one
to save him now there's no one to save
him that died oh you got a pen you got a
pen oh oh this guy's coming in to help
him out like he has like a million
hearts how is he alive there we go there
we go
Oh Chandler coming in God yeah boy get
at me don't try me like that ah well
this person's dead now dream just wiped
the floor with Chandler and we can move
on what dude what's on your sword dude
he's behind me terima somehow in front
of him and behind him yeah it's like the
exact same time is that like a technique
who me another dream the guy doing good
me bro it's totally mean he's Riptide
yeah bro I'm gonna Riptide your booty ho
yay Taylor died no dream I'm about to
make this so hard you won't be able to
survive ten minutes I want to at least
get to a hundred thousand here you go
I'm even gonna give you some blocks
dream you use those legs whenever you
feel comfortable thank you everything up
to this point dream has been easy mode
are you the world's best minecraft
player maybe well then prove it I'm
gonna die it'll be easy Carl
Chandler Chris are you guys ready for
war
you three by yourself stand no chance
against dream that's true just to be
honest dream would wipe the floor with
you filthy animals you guys are nothing
compared to truth which is why we need
70 more people server teleport 70
players and I'm gonna unleash the
floodgates first one to kill dream wins
$10,000 go go alright about dream what's
going through your mind right now I'm
gonna die everyone attack wait are you
gonna just camp this ladder right here
oh just for a little bit this for a
little bit oh god no do not do what do
not build this staircase
well let's see if any notice first 70
minecraft players they seem to be
playing pretty stupid
ah he's camping I've built the stairway
up look at this oh my gosh he's fighting
the Horde ah all right he's getting
overrun
there are so many people here Jamie
might want to abandon ship oh he's gone
he's gone Chris alright alright oh my
gosh how he's still managing to kill
people with all these people sprinting
at him ah look at the leaderboard people
are piling up the leaderboard cuz
they're killing each other instead of
dream oh my gosh dream is going down
there are so many people I'm actually I
think I can actually win this James
still alive what's going on in here I'm
trying to lead them to a place where I
can just end them all like right here
but ah oh you sweaty nerd dream how many
hearts do I keep going down a little bit
but not a lot I'm gonna need you to drop
your helmet no it's gonna break you drop
your helmet five five five also server
spawn 30 more people oh god this is
gonna be the end Oh dream is just eating
right now also dream don't forget you up
blocks up nope that's cheating
kid
you remind me I had blocks for nothing
boom
boink be a shame if somebody just kept
you right there wasn't a dream
I like it here this is my favorite spot
it'd be a shame if someone just put a
water bucket up Oh that'd be a shame
right there oh yeah oh yeah we get good
hits a baby dream we get it dude you're
good at minecraft who's gonna get the 10
G's alright his boots broke I'm laying
water to mess with dreams mojo ah there
are so many people here don't die dream
if you die you're bad come on no no oh
he's done right here watch this this is
it oh they got a pen on the tyro
I'm just tagging dream into corners no
no oh he's it's about to have to pop
another gavel hey that's cheating sir
that's cheating No get him oh his armor
is braisepants break oh he's been Oh No
who got it daba rip Deborah are you in
the call listen I am here to inform you
that you almost got the kill you came in
second place oh just kidding you're the
one who killed dream you're the new
official best minecraft player in the
world and just won $10,000 I'm sorry so
much emotions how old are you I'm going
to be 14 dream anything you want to say
before we go I am NOT the world's best
minecraft player and with that
subscriber we'll see in the next video